our city is saturated with ritual if
people don't talk about that they talk
about how wild and crazy it is pushing
boundaries its innovative engine of
innovation and all this stuff and and I
guess that's radical enough pushing
boundaries going where no one's been the
new but it's really about also in equal
force the old it's about the other side
of what rich with radical means radical
means pushing boundaries it's a very
funny word its root is radix which means
root and if radical the word also means
whatever is deeply situated in our
nature but what what what what what what
is innate what what what is soulful what
is interior it means both those things
at once in our city means both those
things that I might keep out wondering
if people will finally ask me well this
radical expression of radical
self-reliance there's always radical
stuck to the principles what does that
mean
well it in some sense it being said the
people can live in the moment there but
at the same time they do so in
contemplation of continuities of time
that extend all the way back you know to
the beginning say your birth day when
you came into this world as being and
all the way forward potentially into the
future and that future that if you live
long enough then you very much hope to
effect
[Music]